herzlich willkommen das ist zdf heute
live schönen guten morgen ist ja das war
es also das letzte tv duell vor der us
wahl zwischen joe biden und donald trump
und was soll man sagen es war
tatsächlich eine debatte sie haben sich
gegenseitig ausreden lassen sie sind
sich nicht ins wort gefallen es ging
tatsächlich um inhalte und das lag nicht
nur an einer ziemlich zapfen und
straighten moderatorin sondern auch an
einer anderen sache ja also wir erleben
einen donald trump der sich an die
regeln hält der höflich ist der
moderatorin zugewandt der sich bedankt
wenn er nochmal einen einschub machen
darf und joe biden hat sich auch an eben
diese regeln gehalten
das muss ziemlich wohltuend gewesen sein
für die millionen amerikaner die dieses
tv-duell verfolgt haben wie hat das auf
euch gewirkt wenn ihr es geguckt hat
oder wenn ihr jetzt die ausschnitte seht
wir möchten gerne eure kommentare und
eure fragen hören wie immer in die
kommentarspalten oder wenn ihr die zdf-
heute- app nutzt über diese e mail
adresse m at wissen ist unser
korrespondent in washington schönen
guten morgen beziehungsweise schönen
guten abend nach amerika immer wie hat
dieses duell auf sie gewirkt
gründe waren wir alle ein bisschen
überrascht wir hatten eigentlich damit
gerechnet dass es jetzt an dem abend
dann doch normale menge vorwürfe gibt
der präsident möglicherweise auch die
moderatorin verbal attackieren würde das
hat er jedenfalls in den letzten tagen
schon auf twitter gemacht
das hat er dann auch unterlassen und man
hatte einen donald trump heute abend bei
der debatte von dem man sich vielleicht
ein stück weit wünschte dass so auch der
amerikanische präsident in den letzten
jahren hätten sein müssen
da haben seine berater eben sehr klar
gesagt du musst punktesammeln du musst
deine erfolge herausstreichen du musst
ein bisschen höflich sein und genau hat
das hat donald trump weitgehend gemacht
er wusste ja auch ich denke mal einen
großen hebel vollführen denn er liegt in
den umfragen weit hinten und deswegen
braucht ja eigentlich ein durchbruch bei
dieser debatte
deswegen hat er sich zwar ganz gut
geschlagen aber am ende das muss man
sagen das sagen auch die allerersten
umfragen liegt beiden dennoch in den
umfragen vorne
wenn wir schon mal direkt in die inhalte
einsteigen hat man das gefühl gehabt
dass vielleicht weniger krawall und ja
also wir dass es weniger krawall gegeben
hat dafür aber vielleicht mehr lügen das
werden jetzt bestimmt die fakten checker
noch purple schicken müssen aber es gibt
zum beispiel schon auf youtube einen
kommentar von rees bienen im corner ich
hoffe dass es richtig so der schreibt
das waren zwar lügner auf hochtouren
jeder hat den anderen beschuldigt mehr
zu lügen können sie dazu schon was sagen
also auch bei cia dann gibt es ja den
berühmten modell ein sehr genialer
kollege sage ich einfach mal der
wirklich sich zum ziel gemacht hat immer
die fakten zu überprüfen oder die
äußerungen zu überprüfen ob sie den
fakten entsprechen
der kommt zu dem schluss ja beide seiten
haben falsch halten und unwahrheiten
verbreitet aber in viel größerem ausmaß
so wie das auch bei den letzten debatten
der fall war donald trump der an vielen
stellen tatsächlich einfach mal so dinge
herbei gelogen hat zum beispiel über die
krone situation in den usa aber auch zu
wirtschaftsthemen
während joe biden ich sag mal erstens
viel weniger unterwegs waren mit lügen
aber auch ein stück weit subtiler das
heißt er hat vielleicht die wahrheit
nicht ganz so gesagt wie sie auch
wirklich ist die fakten nicht so
dargestellt sondern sie sich an der
einen oder anderen stelle mal
zurechtgebogen aber kein vergleich die
meisten lügen kamen von dolmetschern und
befolge gleich in die themen einsteigen
detailliert corona aussenpolitik steuern
rassismus fast britta jäger den abend
gestern in nashville tennessee zusammen
bloß kein chaos wie beim letzten
aufeinandertreffen zwischen donald trump
und so banken neue regeln sollten es
richten ein stumpf schaltknopf an beiden
mikrofonen damit jeder 20
pro thema ununterbrochen reden konnte
erster und wichtigster punkt die crawler
pandemie ich hab's mir das virus
eingefangen und ich habe viel gelernt 99
9 prozent der jungen leute erholen sich
davon 99 prozent der leute insgesamt
wir müssen die schulen wieder öffnen wir
können diese nationen nicht runterfahren
er sagt wir lernen damit zu leben die
leute lernen zu sterben wie leute die
nun einen leeren platz am küchentisch
was haben sie gegen die gefahr gemacht
sie sagen ich übernehme keine
verantwortung
jedes wort beider kandidaten wird dieses
mal gehört werden versprach die
moderatorin den zuschauern
sie sollte recht behalten vor allem
präsident trump legte den schalter um
weniger aggressiv er sprach ruhig wollte
zeigen ich kann auch höflich ich möchte
darauf reagieren darf ich danke das weiß
ich zu schätzen
die zuschauer wollen mehr inhalt war die
erkenntnis aus den umfragen nach dem
letzten duell
dieses mal hatte trump auf seine berater
gehört doch der präsident konnte nicht
allzu viel bieten joe biden kam dagegen
mit detaillierten plänen zur bekämpfung
des corona virus zu krankenversicherung
zum umgang mit nordkorea
beim thema steuererklärung versuchte
beiden tram festzunageln ich habe
millionen an dollar gezeigt sogar noch
schlimmer ich habe voraus sie sie uns
hören sie auf ihn zu ihren zusagen seit
vier jahren sowie ihre steuererklärung
veröffentlichen keiner weiß was aber wir
wissen sie zahlen ihre steuern an der
grenze zu mexiko hatte die trump
regierung illegal eingereist die kinder
und eltern voneinander getrennt die
eltern hunderter kinder lassen sich nun
nicht mehr ausfindig machen was tun
fragt die moderatorin
wir arbeiten hart daran aber viele
dieser kinder kamen ohne eltern sie kam
über kanten schlepper unlängst das waren
keine schlepper die diese kinder
brachten das waren die eltern die wurden
von ihren eltern getrennt das macht uns
zum gespött und verletzt alles was wir
als
versucht es immer wieder mit dem vorwurf
beiden und seine familie würden sich
persönlich bereichern
sein kontrahent pariert nach 90 minuten
trennen sie sich nach einer debatte die
diesen namen tatsächlich verdient hat ja
immer woran hat es gelegen dass trump
seine taktik geändert hat und auf seine
berater gehört hat hat er nicht mehr
versucht die leute zu erreichen die er
sowieso schon erreicht sondern versucht
dadurch neue wähler dazu zu gewinnen
oder wie kann man sich das erklären
ja ich glaube der präsident hat in den
letzten wochen zunächst einmal wert
darauf gelegt seine anhänger seine
glühenden anhänger auf jeden fall bei
sich zu binden an sich zu binden auch
für diese wahl denn nur wenn sie alle
wieder kommen und ihn wählen hat er
eigentlich eine chance hat er die letzte
wahl vor vier jahren eigentlich nur in
drei bundesstaaten mit insgesamt 77.000
stimmen mehr gewonnen also diese ganzen
anhänger muss er wieder mobilisieren
da ihm aber das sagen die umfragen sehr
umfragen sehr klar einige auch von der
fahne gegangen sind das sind besonders
zum beispiel die frauen in den
vorstädten oder die älteren menschen in
den usa teilweise eben auch die
schwarzen in den usa die in weniger
wählen als vor vier jahren und da muss
ja irgendwie ich sage mal ersatz für
finden und deswegen vielleicht dieses
zivile auftreten seine berater haben ihm
jedenfalls gesagt so muss es sein weil
nur so eine chance besteht in den
entscheidenden bundesstaaten bei denen
es knapp werden könnte am ende dann die
fahrer die nase vorn zu haben
dann steigen wir mal ein in die inhalte
und gucken uns gleich noch mal an was er
zu corona gesagt hat zuvor aber noch
eine frage an sie ist ja interessant er
war infiziert er ist gestern der einzige
gewesen der keine maske getragen hat
haben wir ja gerade gesehen da auf der
bühne
das ist ja auch ein signal und
gleichzeitig haben sich vielleicht viele
gefragt warum er seine eigene infektion
nicht stärker thematisiert hat in diesem
duell
ja er hat sie thematisiert aber auch da
glaube ich hatte er sich zurückgehalten
weil er er wert darauf gelegt hat zu
sagen dass corona gar nicht so
gefährlich ist hat schon sich selbst
auch als beispiel angeführt hat ja die
zahlen genannt die wir vor in dem
beitrag
gehört haben die stimmen teilweise nicht
also dass 99 prozent der menschen in den
usa sich so problemlos wieder von corona
erholen wie er das angeblich tut das ist
einfach eine lüge das stimmt welche sind
mehrere prozent die auch erhebliche
nachwirkungen haben auch schwere
schädigungen haben an ihren organen
also er hat sich da ein bisschen
zurückgehalten sich in den vordergrund
zu spielen das habe ihnen aber nicht
davon abgehalten die korona krise als
solche ist eigentlich herunterzuspielen
und schon wieder diesen satz zu sagen
das geht vorbei und das kommt bei den
menschen draußen im land vielleicht
nicht so gut an weil ihre
lebenswirklichkeit ist das gegenteil in
vielen bundesstaaten schießen die
infektionszahlen nach oben und nicht nur
die sondern auch die zahl der menschen
die im krankenhaus sind und auch die
todesopfer pro tag etwa 1000 die wir zu
beklagen haben in der korona krise ich
glaube ich habe gelesen dass er diesen
satz dass die pandemie schon bald vorbei
sein wird insgesamt 39 mal gesagt hat
seit beginn der pandemie mir hör mal
rein sie haben gerade schon ein paar
beispiele genannt was er zu chor oder
gestern abend gesagt hat zwei millionen
menschen sind bereits identifiziert als
bedroht von dieser grauenhaften
krankheit die aus china zu uns gekommen
ist das ist mittlerweile eine pandemie
die auf europa betrifft wir haben aber
mittlerweile deutlich niedrigere
mortalität wenn wir uns mit anderen
ländern vergleichen
wir haben ihm in wenigen wochen an
impfstoff parat und unser militär wird
dafür sorgen dass dieser impfstoff
verteilt wird
220.000 amerikaner sind gestorben
niemand kann sagen ich kann keine
verantwortung dafür übernehmen
jeder der für so viele tote
verantwortlich ist sollte sich präsident
der usa bleiben wenn man einfach nur
diese masken getragen hätte hätte man
hunderttausende von leben retten können
und der präsident hatte nie einen plan
und hat auch jetzt keinen plan zur
bekämpfung der pandemie
ich möchte sicherstellen dass wir alle
dazu ermutigen die maske immer zu tragen
dass wir sehr schnell im schnelltests
investieren und dass wir nationale
standards definieren dafür wie das
unternehmen und das öffentliche leben
hochgefahren werden können
das jump diesmal die maske getragen hat
auf dem podium wir uns ja gerade schon
angesprochen und wir haben sie auch
gerade noch mal gesehen wie joe biden
dafür wirbt die maske zu tragen um
weiteres schlimmes zu verhindern
elmar wie sie sehr oder wie stark
gefährdet denn trumps corona krisen
management seine wiederwahl
also eigentlich sehr weil die menschen
draußen wissen dass das was er jetzt vor
hin auch wieder gesagt hat was wir
gerade gehört haben zum guten teil
einfach herr logan ist also die zahl die
er da verwendet hat in dem statement
waren mal mindestens 56 lügen ich immer
ein beispiel nennen wissenschaftler
haben errechnet und das kann man glaube
ich sehr gut errechnen wie viel
amerikaner möglicherweise sie ihr leben
nicht verloren hätten wenn man maske
getragen hätte wenn man immer abstand
gehalten hätte wenn man sich an die
maßnahmen von einigen bundesstaaten
gehalten hätte die bundesregierung in
washington hat wenig dazu beigetragen
dass in irgendeiner weise abzumelden
oder bildern oder die eigenen regeln die
vom center for disease control ja
verhängt worden sind dann auch
durchzusetzen im gegenteil der präsident
hat schlechtes vorbild gegeben er hat im
grunde um aufgefordert man soll sich
doch gegen die gouverneure auflehnen die
zu harte maßnahmen verhängen usw
und er geht einfach hin und nimmt eine
an
studie die einfach nur mal hochgerechnet
hat was wäre wenn man überhaupt nichts
getan hätte gar nichts also wenn auch
nicht jeder einzelne amerikaner
vielleicht oder zumindest die die die
angst hatten
wenn die keine maske getragen hätten
wenn die keinen abstand gehalten hätten
wenn die einzelnen bundesstaaten oder
die einzelnen städte keine maßnahmen
ergriffen hätten dann wäre es bei 2,2
millionen gelandet so war die
hochrechnung aber daraus kann man nicht
schließen dass der amerikanische
präsident durch sein verhalten millionen
von menschenleben gerettet hat ich
glaube das schadet ihm wenn er das so
tut weil die lebenswirklichkeit jetzt
gerade sieht so aus dass die zahlen in
die höhe schnellen einige bundesstaaten
feldlazarette aufstellen müssen weil die
krankenhäuser überfordert sind und die
gouverneure selber der zoom von utah
beispielsweise hat sich im fernsehen
geäußert sie erwarten das ist jetzt noch
viel schlimmer wird in den nächsten
wochen und dann als präsident sich
hinzustellen und zu sagen das vergeht
jetzt wieder und wir sind schon längst
über alle berge nennt das moratorium
corner
wir sind über den berg so kann man zu
übersetzen das ist nicht die
lebenswirklichkeit der amerikaner
draußen zu dieser lebenswirklichkeit
gehört auch dazu dass es seit wochen und
monaten eine große rassismus debatte
ergibt und auch darüber wurde gestern
abend gesprochen und da sagt donald
trump niemand hat mehr getan gegen
rassismus als donald trump ich musste
meine tochter nie sagen wenn die
polizeidichte wo anhält legt beide hände
oben auf das lenkrad und greift nicht
ins handschuhfach weil jemand dir
schießen könnte ein schwarzes als
schwarze eltern aber egal wie reich oder
arm müssen ihren kindern sagen wenn du
die straße überquert betrag einen
kapuzenpullover wenn du an gehalten wird
sagt immer nur yes yes to lose lasst die
hände oben auf dem lenkrad weil du
gefahr läuft sonst erschossen zu werden
er hat selber tatsächlich schwarze
menschen als raubtiere bezeichnet das
war bei der neuen gesetzgebung zu
straftaten 1994
niemand hat mehr
für die schwarzen in diesem land getan
als donald trump als er selber hat sogar
gesagt keiner hat mehr für die schwarzen
getan seit abraham lincoln als er hat
sich mit einem großen amerikanischen
präsidenten verglichen
daraufhin hat joe biden ihn frotzelnd
gewissermaßen als abraham lincoln
angesprochen und gesagt dann wäre
abraham lincoln ja ein rassist weil
dieser präsident das hat beiden ganz
klar ausgesprochen sei ein rassist warum
weil er rechtsextremistische und
rassistische milizen in amerika ermutigt
dass sie gewalt anwenden dass sie
möglicherweise auch sich bereithalten
sollen für einen ungewissen wahlausgang
aber da ist eben ein rassistisches
gedankengut vorhanden in dieser rechten
szene in den usa so sich dann selber
hinzustellen und zu sagen ich bin der
der am meisten gegen rassismus getan hat
das ist sicherlich falsch aber trump hat
auch einen wichtigen punkt für sich
gelandet er hat joe biden vorgeworfen er
hätte doch in seiner zeit als
vizepräsident selber mehr gegen
rassismus tun können indem er zum
beispiel eine strafrechtsreform
durchsetzt also das wieder zurückdreht
an nachdem er vorher selber mitgewirkt
hatte das hätte er ja selber als
vizepräsident machen können und das ist
sage ich mal ganz klar das hätte er in
der tat das hat er nicht und das ist
eine wunde stelle bei joe biden
geblieben da hat also der präsident mal
einen punkt gemacht
ich möchte gern ein journalistisches
logo machen und eine doppel frage
stellen und zwar fragt thomas rabenstein
auf facebook das fast nämlich genau dazu
hat sich trump diesmal deutlicher von
rassismus und seine braut boys
distanziert und die nächste frage von
thomas rabenstein möchte ich gerne
anschließen weil die zum nächsten thema
überleitet er fragt war die
einflussnahme aus dem ausland auf die us
wahl wieder ein thema ja also zum ersten
punkt er hat sich nicht distanziert man
muss aber sagen er wurde auch nicht klar
noch mal dazu aufgefordert oder danach
gefragt es wurde als thema kurz
angetippt und er hätte die gelegenheit
gehabt das nachzuholen was er beim
letzten mal versäumt hat also hat sich
nicht distanziert weder von den milizen
noch von
den kanon verschwörungs anhängern also
das hat er versäumt hier bei der debatte
und die andere frage ausländischer
einfluss auf die us wahlen ja das war
ein wichtiges thema im thema nationale
sicherheit weil am vorabend ja hier das
fbi und der geheimdienstkoordinator in
washington bekannt gegeben haben dass
besonders russland und der iran
versuchen die amerikanische wahl zu
beeinflussen der iran sogar gefälschte
e-mails streut an wähler wo ihnen
gedroht wird angeblich im namen von
irgendwelchen rechtsextremen milizen
da stecke der iran dahinter das treibt
die menschen hier natürlich schon ein
stück weit um mehr wer greift er wieder
von außen ein in den amerikanischen
wahlkampf aber beide haben im brunnen
gesagt dass sie sich das verbieten der
stärkere war sicherlich joe biden der
ganz klar gesagt hat wenn wir den
hinweis oder belegt darauf haben dass es
russland ist dass der iran dahinter
steckt dann werde er dafür sorgen dass
die dafür bezahlen müssen als er kündigt
ganz klar an er als präsident würde dann
auch gegen diese staaten vorgehen weil
die wahl das heiligste ist und dass ein
eingriff in eine souveräne nation sei
und joe biden hat natürlich den
präsidenten vorgeworfen er habe gegen
wladimir putin in den letzten jahren nur
einen kuschelkurs gefahren und hat
bisher auch noch nicht reagiert auf die
hinweise dass russland tatsächlich
wieder versucht einfluss auf die
amerikanische wahl zu nehmen
dann geht es dann nicht nur um einfluss
auf die wahl sondern auch um einfluss
auf politiker und die frage wer von wem
ja oder nein geld von wem aus dem
ausland bekommen hat und auch da gab es
vorwürfe in beide richtungen schon rein
ich bin wirklich opfer einer hexenjagd
geworden drei jahre das gedauert das war
sogar schon vor meiner wahl dagegen das
los niemand hätte das erleiden sollen
was ich erleiden musste ich bin
untersucht worden ich bin opfer dieser
hexenjagd geworden und es ist nichts
gefunden worden gegen mich
was man weiß ist dass sie ihre steuern
nicht zahlen oder sie zahlen steuern
aber so wenig letzte mal sagte er ich
habe doch nur so wenig gezahlt weil ich
so smart bin ich weiß wie man das system
ausnutzt kommt leute aus dem ausland
bekommt aus china oder aus russland und
welche familie sich da jetzt wie
bereichert hängt eng zusammen mit der
frage wie viel steuern in amerika
gezahlt werden und da haben wir auch
gestern wieder keine klare antwort
gehört wannen trump seine
steuererklärung vorlegen will er sagt
ich mache das ich habe alles in die wege
geleitet aber ein datum hat er nicht
genannt
ja er war ich da aus das muss man klar
sagen er hat kein datum genannt während
joe biden seine steuererklärungen ja
vorgelegt hat wichtig war aber glaube
ich dass es ja auch einen konkreten
vorwurf gehabt donald trump an joe biden
er habe mit seiner familie 3,5 millionen
aus russland kassiert gelder bekommen
das bezieht sich auf vorwürfe dass der
sohn von joe biden in geschäfte in
illegale geschäfte verwickelt gewesen
sein könnte und dafür dann geld an die
beiden familie gegangen ist auch aus
china das sind jedenfalls die vorwürfe
joe biden hat ganz klar gesagt da ist
nichts dran in der sache ukraine
russland sei das ja untersucht worden
und alle sagen da ist nichts dran nichts
strafbares da gab es das alles nicht
oder auch was china angeht kommt er zu
einem sehr klaren schluss er sagt zitat
ich habe noch niemals auch nur einen
penny von irgendeinem menschen aus dem
ausland angenommen
ein ganz klarer satz wenn der nicht
stimmen würde und es in den nächsten
tagen noch bewiesen würde das gebäude
liegt dann könnte ihm das wirklich auf
die füße fallen
aber es wäre ein großes risiko so einen
satz zu sagen man hätte sich an der
stelle gewünscht dass vielleicht auch
donald trump so ein satz mal offen
aussprechen könnte
wir bleiben mal bei den blick ins
ausland und schauen ganz kurz nur auf
ein ganz besonderes verhältnis nämlich
auf dass zwischen donald trump und kim
jong un
wir sind nicht im krieg wir haben ein
gutes verhältnis die leute sagen wenn
man ein gutes verhältnis hat dann ist
das eine gute sache
und wir hatten ein gutes verhältnis zu
hitler bevor er in europa ein viel da
immer tee wissen wir wissen hitler
vergleiche gehen meistens schief ist
dieser gelungen
ja aber vielleicht ein bisschen sehr
weit gegriffen aber was schon beiden
dann auch mit argumenten untermauert hat
er hat gesagt dass nach vier jahren
trump nordkorea gefährlicher ist als
vorher sein nuklearpotenzial sogar
ausgebaut hat und zwar in potenzial mit
dem auch amerikanisches festland
erreicht werden könnte also im grunde
genommen hat der argumente dafür
geliefert auch wenn der der der der
vergleich hier vielleicht ein bisschen
gewagt erscheint weil wir nicht mehr so
viel zeit haben weil materie sind ein
gefragter mannes und fürs morgenmagazin
geschaltet wird würde ich ja gerne die
letzten zwei minuten noch für zwei
schnelle fragen nutzen auf youtube
beschreibt ep 2000 gibt es umfragen in
den usa welcher kandidat in der debatte
mehr überzeugt hat ja es gibt eine
umfrage von cnn ist eine blitzumfrage da
ist zu hören
53 prozent der die debatte gesehen haben
sagen beiden habe die debatte debatte
klar gewonnen
trump lag mit seiner zeit nicht so weit
zurück also irgendwo in den vierzigern
ich habe sie nicht mehr genau im kopf
besser als beim letzten mal
aber man muss immer dazu sagen diese
schnell umfragen nach einer debatte die
sind vielleicht auch nicht so belastbar
und letzte frage auf ebenfalls auf
youtube schreibt viel es hat trump
wieder offen gelassen ob er das ergebnis
annehmen wird
dazu ist es dann gar nicht mehr gekommen
dass man noch mal konkret danach gefragt
hat da steht immer noch der satz im raum
vom letzten mal
auch von einem townhall meeting was er
ja gehabt hat wo er sehr kritisch
befragt worden ist also nach wie vor
kein klares bekenntnis von donald trump
dazu dass er eine niederlage auch
wirklich anerkennen würde dann sind wir
gespannt wie die wahl in knapp zwei
wochen ausgeht vielen dank elmar
theveßen nach washington und vielen dank
liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
userinnen
und user fürs mitmachen und zuschauen
dankeschön tschüss einen schönen tag
[Musik]